[Music]
on this tuesday night the warning for
canadians
bend the curve not the rules public
health officials fear explosive growth
of covid19
driven by young people i would call it
the invincibility factor you know i
think at a certain age you think
you can get away with anything could
tough restrictions soon
reappear the prime minister grilled
about his ties to the wii charity
so gross and disgusting that this prime
minister keeps
using the pandemic as an excuse for his
corruption
plus new insight into the charities
financial affairs
officials did not engage in
detailed scrutiny what's going on on the
streets of portland
the growing protests and the crackdown
by federal agents
sent in by president trump and changing
the name
what edmonton's cfl team has finally
decided
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
with summer now in full swing and many
bars restaurants and shops open again
there are signs the progress canadians
made limiting the spread of kovid 19
could be lost
case numbers are rising in multiple
provinces there were an average of about
300 new cases per day across the country
earlier this month over the last four
days that jumped to about 460
new cases each day ontario reported more
than 200 new cases today the highest
number there in several weeks
quebec also had an uptick 180 new cases
today the highest
since mid-june bc and alberta have also
reported spikes recently
all the sacrifices all all the the great
efforts that canadians have
made to date in terms of flattening the
curve we need to be mindful that
you know that success is fragile that it
only takes a few sparks and sort of
people letting go we could backslide and
unfortunately
return to situation as we had several
months ago
in british columbia the provincial
health officer dr bonnie henry says she
is worried about
rising case numbers that and they could
trigger she says an explosive
growth as global's richard zussman
reports people are being warned to use
more
caution or face the consequences
it's been one of the covet 19
catchphrases on the west coast
then the curve not the rules but after
months of knocking down the virus in
british columbia
the curve is now bending in the wrong
direction we were at a bit of a tipping
point
we now have started to see cases
increase our curve is bending up
bc has been praised globally for the
province's work at reducing the spread
of the virus
but new modeling data shows the latest
trends a recent uptick in cases in the
province
the recent story unfolding this way low
new cases on july 1
slowly creeping back up what this shows
is that we do
have a possibility of having explosive
growth
in our con in our in our outbreak here
in bc
if we're not careful in how we progress
over the summer
in alberta a similar story fewer
restrictions means more interactions
and no matter where you live that means
more new cases of the virus
we know now that we're traveling more
we're going to work we're going to
different settings
so we are having contacts with most
people with more people
what we need to do is have those as safe
contacts
the focus here in bc and nationwide are
people in their 20s and 30s
a recent exposure including all young
people at bars and restaurants in
kelowna bc's wine country
led to 60 covet 19 cases and counting
prompting a new strategy for public
health so we have
there for example in delivering our
message a lot of social influencers who
have been involved in putting out
messages in the last few days
but social media messages aren't enough
and british columbia is looking at
further regulations
we are going to have to adjust and
adjust
and adjust again and again and again
throughout this pandemic which i remind
everybody is not going away
there is no cure health officials know
people are getting sick and tired of
restrictions
but say being sick with kova 19 is far
worse than being frustrated about it
richard joins me now richard what no one
wants to do is go backward into tighter
restrictions again
how real is that possibility and we know
what it might look like in bc
the first step it seems to be donna will
be increased
regulations and then potentially
stricter restrictions
and we know the focus here in bc and
many other places in the country will be
around
contact tracing so the province looks to
be tightening rules around
ensuring that if young people interact
with people they don't know
that they have their contact information
donna
all right richard zusman in victoria
tonight thank you
prime minister justin trudeau for the
first time faced questions in the house
of commons about his connections
to the we charity the organization with
close ties to his family that would have
been paid tens of millions of dollars
for a government contract and more
information came to light today from key
witnesses
testifying at a committee abigail beeman
reports
i don't have a question mr speaker it's
just disgusting
question period fireworks as the prime
minister faced heat on we in the house
of commons for the first time
will the prime minister do the right
thing show up and testify a committee
justin trudeau didn't answer that
he did repeat his mia culpa i should
have recused myself because of the
connection with the families but that
doesn't my family but that doesn't take
away from the fact that the public
service recommended that organization
hours before canada's top bureaucrat was
grilled about that recommendation at the
finance committee
to the best of my knowledge there were
no
detailed investigations of we charities
financial affairs
a global news investigation found ottawa
has announced millions of dollars for we
charity
dating back to the stephen harper years
but since the trudeau liberals took
power in 2015
the amount doubled to at least five and
a half million dollars according to
spending reports
we stood to make 43.5 million dollars in
the now canceled deal
for the student grant program worth 900
million
ian shugert told committee for a program
that big he saw
no way the finance minister and prime
minister couldn't
have been involved and he offered this
defense for justin trudeau
the prime minister's involvement being
in the public domain
i must say that it it it did not
particularly cross my mind that there
was anything
that needed to be disclosed because this
was a
a well-known fact at the at the time
and while shugart also repeated the
government's line that the public
service wouldn't have been able to
provide the same program
the head of their union told the
committee something else
the public service has proven itself
very capable
accountable and certainly
absolutely been able to administer this
program more questions to come wednesday
when the finance
minister takes the hot seat at the same
committee and
next week wii's co-founders brothers
mark and craig kielberger
will do the same abigail beeman global
news
ottawa in edmonton the city's cfl team
has finally decided to drop the word
eskimo from its name the team known for
decades as the edmonton eskimos will go
by the name the ee
football team or the edmonton football
team for now it says it's
still working on a new name in the past
the franchise had said it had no plans
to drop the word
eskimo today the board of directors said
public attitudes
are shifting
people who defended the name only a year
ago are less comfortable with
it now institutions are being renamed
around the world the change to our name
is part of a sweeping societal change
a week ago washington's nfl team
announced it is dropping the word
redskins from its name
the team had been facing growing
pressure from sponsors
now to another story we're tracking in
alberta the investigation into that
crash of a tourist bus on the columbia
ice field
authorities say it may take months to
determine what caused it
three people were killed among them a 24
24 year old woman from saskatchewan
as heather urix west reports her
grieving partner
is calling for change it was deion de
roches first
trip to the rocky mountains a
sightseeing adventure that was supposed
to be
a trip of a lifetime every night i cried
for my girlfriend
i tell her i'm sorry i love you i wish i
never bring you here
it's all i could think of devon earnest
says it happened
so fast he and derose were among the 24
people on an ice explorer tour bus
heading to the athabasca glacier
when the 25-ton vehicle began to roll
we started going down the steep hill and
i hear the front wheel
slid off and the last thing i see was
the roof
the last thing i seen i was flying to
the roof ernest says when he woke up he
thought deroche was ok
so we hurried to check on his cousin
first when i went turning back to my
girlfriend
she just she had her eyes closed and she
wasn't breathing no more
rcmp say the investigation into what
caused the crash will take
time just removing the large bus from
the scene is slow and pain staking work
the rollover happened on what's known as
glacier moraine
steep and rocky terrain made up of
sediment that has been gradually eroded
by the melting ice
the road itself is challenging and so
the
the nature of the challenging road is
because of the
rapid thaw and change in this glacial
landscape
climate change has meant the athabasca
glacier is melting quickly in glacier
terms
and may only be accessible to tourists
for another few decades
the rapid melt makes the glacier moraine
even more unstable but investigators
have ruled out any kind of rock or
landslide
as a contributing factor in the crash
the tour operator
jasper collection by pursuit has relied
on a fleet of ice explorers for decades
they are specially designed to navigate
steep terrain but there are no seat
belts on board
as he grieves his loss devon earnest
says he would like to see
some changes made are they gonna ask
seat belts are they gonna have
railings on there something to keep us
in that spot if
another rollover appears heather urex
west
global news calgary
the quebec man who police said was on
the run after his two daughters were
found murdered
has been found police now believe marte
carpentier took his own life
he is the main suspect in the deaths of
his young daughters
as mike armstrong explains his body was
found just a few hours
after their funeral the
grisly discovery was made by a homeowner
he called police around 7 p.m monday
after finding a body in the wooded area
behind his garage
that homeowner would end up having to be
treated for shock police say they
believe it to be malte capacity
and that he took his own life
this man says he'd hoped kappance would
be found alive so he could better
understand what happened
now there was a massive effort to find
capacity for more than a week dozens and
dozens of officers
scoured the region well where he was
found is an area searchers had checked
in fact police admit it was one of the
first areas they searched
it was only about three kilometers from
the command center police set up for the
manhunt
cal ponte's daughters were found several
kilometers to the west
it all leaves the question did they miss
the body or did they check and then
kappanciat came
later the body's been taken for an
autopsy that will formally confirm the
identity and the cause of death
it'll also start filling in some of the
timeline six-year-old remy and
eleven-year-old nara were found july
11th
kappance's body wasn't recovered for
nine more days
police still aren't saying whether any
sort of a note was found or whether they
have any information about his emotional
state
but there's fear it may never be
understood
there are a lot of questions that will
never be answered this woman says that's
what i found most disappointing for both
families police say they're sifting
through what they've found and waiting
for the results from the autopsy
they've called a press conference for
wednesday afternoon in montreal
at provincial police headquarters mike
armstrong global news
montreal not
backing down coming up defiance in the
face of federal agents
sent into portland by president trump
the protests in portland oregon which
began in late may after the death of
george floyd have persisted and now
they've grown into a national flashpoint
about president trump's law and order
agenda he sent in federal agents many
operate without id and in full
camouflage gear
they grab protesters off the street put
them in unmarked vehicles
hold them without due process some
protesters
have been violent but there's been
peaceful pushback too
like this woman wearing nothing but a
mask and a hat confronting heavily armed
agents
jackson proskow on a standoff the world
is watching
there's no end in sight to the protests
gripping portland
for more than 50 days marchers have
taken to the streets
only to be met in recent days by a force
of federal agents
men without badges or id acting on
orders of president donald trump
didn't deter me it may deter me it made
me in fact want to go back
monday saw a march of mums met with tear
gas near a federal courthouse
video of people being grabbed off the
streets and hauled away
in unmarked vans by the unidentified men
have fueled the protests
so did video showing a 53 year old navy
veteran
beaten and pepper sprayed after he tried
to talk to the officers about their oath
to defend the constitution
this community is being intentionally
disrupted and
i think we can all see that
if we don't get this to stop it will
spread to other cities
the white house has no plans to stop
with portland
vowing to confront a variety of alleged
threats like crime and gun violence
matters typically reserved for local
police we're looking at chicago too
we're looking at new york
look at what's going on all run by
democrats
the move is a distraction from the
raging pandemic and the president's own
faltering approval ratings i think that
our president
is essentially throwing mud on the wall
to find an issue
that will help him carry the day in
november the use of federal agents as
police was previewed during protests in
washington d.c
when those same unmarked officers were
stationed outside the white house
we're accomplishing our mission which is
to protect the federal facilities and
the people
in them and using them as the election
draws near and as the pandemic spirals
into a national emergency
there are fears about how and why those
forces are being deployed
for now their presence is only
emboldening protesters
i think what they want to do is scare us
away the feds they want us to stop
protesting and it's the opposite effect
tonight president donald trump is giving
in on the issue of the covid covid19
pandemic he held his first
in-person briefing on the issue in
months he admitted things are likely to
get worse before they get better
but then return to a familiar message
track of downplaying the severity of the
virus
and touting his own administration's
response
donna he is not backing down though over
the issues of law
and order what he claims to be
lawlessness in american cities
something he sees as a potential wedge
issue in the upcoming election
okay jackson prosco in washington thank
you
divided kingdom still ahead scotland's
push for independence gains momentum
during the pandemic
in the uk a long delayed report into
russian influence on british politics
reveals the government
badly underestimated the threat posed by
the kremlin and failed to prepare for
or even look for evidence of
interference in the brexit referendum
the uk government have actively avoided
looking for evidence that russia
interfered we were told that they hadn't
seen any evidence
but that is meaningless if they hadn't
looked for it
the report found the british government
treated defending its democratic
processes as a hot potato
and as a result no agency took
responsibility it calls
russian influence in the uk the new
normal and says successive governments
have welcomed russian oligarchs with
open arms
and it says two years before the brexit
vote there were credible suggestions of
influence campaigns
by russia in the scottish independence
referendum
that vote ended with scotland staying in
the uk but the pro-independence movement
has since gained momentum during the
pandemic
redmond shannon looks at how different
responses to covet 19
have divided the nation
when tony blair became prime minister in
he promised to change how the uk
functions
within two years london handed over many
decision-making powers to national
parliaments in northern ireland
scotland and wales since then the
smaller nations have been making their
own decisions
in areas like health and education not
unlike canadian provinces
and those powers have never been as
important as they are this year
during the coven 19 pandemic we had a
four nations approach initially
and but the devolved nations
increasingly have taken a different
um tangent and in scotland the release
of our lockdown has been
significantly slower than in england
scotland's pro-independence leader
nicholas sturgeon has shown
impatience with some decisions made in
london
for england but that affect scotland
when so much is at stake as it is right
now
we can't allow ourselves to be dragged
along in the wake of
and other governments to be quite frank
about it shambolic
decision-making process the pandemic
coming
immediately after brexit appears to have
reinforced
new support for scottish independence
now polling steadily
above 50 percent the scottish public
think that nicola sturgeon has handled
the coronavirus well very well indeed on
balance
and they think that boris johnson has
not done terribly well
at all scotland's death rate has been
lower than england but not
hugely so however scottish perception of
its
big brother has been influenced by the
huge infection numbers
south of the border and by a prime
minister who nearly died from the virus
you have seen members of the community
trying to stop cars from coming up the
a1 which is the main trajectory
highway into scotland and putting up
signs saying you're not wanted here
english please go away sturgeon's
critics say
she has deliberately politicized the
virus to boost her push for independence
scottish elections are scheduled for
next year if she turns her
minority into a majority expect an
almighty fight with london to get a
rerun of the 2014
independence referendum redmond shannon
global news
london
you're watching global national
music is one way to soothe the soul and
bridge the distance between people
during a pandemic
just ask julia jung a mississauga
teacher
her passion for music and determination
to use technology to bring her students
together
produced this cover version of an arkell
song
[Music]
it struck a chord with the band and
their front man max kerman
who is also giving online music lessons
to people cooped up by the pandemic
well he invited zhang to join him on the
band's instagram
feed and surprised her with a special
guest julia this is our friend coach
nick nurse
so nice to meet you nick nurse the
toronto raptors head coach
julia happens to be a massive raptors
fan and couldn't believe
what the coach said next i got some good
news for you on behalf of e1 and the
nick
nurse foundation um we're going to get
you some new instruments to them
five thousand dollars oh my gosh
oh my gosh that means so much just
because we're so worried about our
programs already
i'd be lost without my music really and
that's part of the reason we're we're
focusing on it in the foundation
the money will go a long way to
addressing the shortage of instruments
in her school
we want to make sure everybody gets the
opportunity to learn i only wish i could
have learned a little more when i was
younger
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this full moon over
downtown mississauga ontario thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye